in this clap minute I want to show you  how to reset a persistent disk without  done time here I have compute engine VM  called my instance and it is a disk  attached called my disk let's click on  my desk and take a look at its size it's  100 gig now let's go back to our  instance and SSH into it and look at the  this size using the F - H command now  let's go back to console and double are  at this size so click on the disk click  edit change size to 200 and it's safe  after you resize your disk  you must reset your partition so that  the operating system can access the  additional space so let's do that using  resize - FS command and note that you do  not have to reboot or even start a new  shell and now let's see that it is  resized and that's it thanks for  watching